oh that's the sound of the dread Wolf
the next installment in biowest Dragon
Age series and unfortunately some
gameplay leaked over the weekend the
biggest takeaway is The Game's shift
toward real-time combat which is
reportedly using the recent God of War
releases as an inspiration various
abilities are also mapped to specific
buttons with an interface that will look
familiar to those who have played
previous Dragon Age entries players have
a basic attack combo abilities and a
meter that when full can be used for a
special attack there is reportedly no
way to control party members directly
but the leaker thinks there will likely
be some way for players to issue
commands though such a feature wasn't in
the alpha build the footage takes place
entirely in the great warden base of
weishault which is being invaded by
darkspawn and culminates with players
facing off against a dragon the Lika
makes a special mention of the game's
animations noting that quote we've never
seen anime quality this good in any
BioWare game a recent report claimed
that Dragon Age dread wolf is perhaps
further away from release than many had
anticipated and will likely not arrive
in 2023. personally I think that a move
toward more God of war-like combat while
retaining other core Dragon Age elements
such as abilities and team commands if
done well is an excellent recipe to
satiate long time fans as well as
drawing new players to the franchise
Lord knows BioWare needs this game to be
a hit and that's only going to happen if
the game captures both of those
audiences from a hit to a punch
OverWatch 2's upcoming third season will
see the franchises first IP
collaboration with a one punch man
doomfist skin which is a match made in
crossover Heaven speaking of matchmaking
the season will also feature a
Valentine's Day event a cupid skin for
Hanzo and a dating Sim browser game
called loverwatch as a reminder season 3
will be skipping adding a new hero with
the plan currently for every other
OverWatch season to update the game's
roster for every detail on OverWatch 2's
third season including a complete list
of Skins new game modes and a look at
its latest Antarctic Peninsula map head
to gamespot.com if nothing about
OverWatch 2's upcoming season speaks to
you maybe another warlong Fallen Dynasty
demo does ahead of its release on March
3rd a new slice of content will be
available from February 24th through
March 26th and features the first two
chapters of the game that were not
featured in the first demo online
multiplayer will also be available and
as an added bonus clearing the first
chapter and transferring the saved data
to the main game will unlock the
crouching dragon helmet when warlong is
released the game will also be available
through Xbox game pass what do you think
about the potential of Dragon Age to
have God of War like combat are you
going to be jumping into OverWatch 2's
third season let us know in the comments
we'll see you here for more games
foreign